israeli police have detained the last
two of six palestinian prisoners who
escaped from a high-security facility
police arrested munadil nafayat and
aiham kamamji in jenin in the occupied
west bank ending a two-week search among
those who tunnelled their way out of
gilboa prison was zachariah zubaidi a
high-profile figure in fatah's armed
wing israeli prosecutors want to add an
additional 15 years to each man's
sentence on charges they were planning a
new attack
before the men were found residents of
janine fought israeli soldiers who
arrived in large numbers to continue
their search one palestinian was injured
jeannine residents say since the
jailbreak thousands of law enforcement
and military have been deployed in their
city
harry fawcett has more from west
jerusalem
there was a statement from the israeli
military saying that there were uh
violence there was violence afterwards
with um
locals from the area uh they said
throwing rocks and improvised explosive
devices at police they reported live
fire as well certainly
we do know that there have been protests
there was concern that if there was a
major violent end to this this manhunt
that it could end in a very bloody way
and potentially spill over into wider
violence so i think the israelis will be
happy that they managed to to get these
men back without that kind of gunfight
at the end of it this was a very major
breach of the israeli security system
there had been a previous attempt in
this jail in 2014 to get out in a very
similar way
that was averted but the
full extent of the security holes had
not obviously been plugged the keyhole
of which is the physical hole under the
prison itself there were void spaces
into which these men managed over many
months to dig into and then dig out of
into the open air and stay on the run in
the case of four of them for nearly a
week in the case of the last two for
nearly two weeks so it is something that
has caused a great deal of embarrassment
for the israeli prison service there are
all sorts of uh investigations into this
precise incident reappraisals of how the
entire prison network operates
and this is something that that the
recapture is something that the prime
minister naftali bennett has greeted
this morning by saying it was
sophisticated and quick uh reported to
be costing many millions of dollars a
day this massive manhunt which has now
ended in this way but but certainly uh
this has been a a major breach and a
major embarrassment for israel's
security apparatus